今天这节课非常重要，为什么呢？我们第一次啊讲这个。
密室片啊，或者是说叫鬼屋片。
嗯，因为鬼怖片一般都带着一些恐怖或惊悚的元素。嗯，坦白说，作为我本人在闲暇时光的时候是很少一个人去欣赏的。
但是呢他确实有他的呃很大的一个市场啊。
特别是在B级片里面也是一股非常不容忽视的存在。所以说今天咱们讲一讲这个算是密室片里面非常经典的一种类型啊，非常经典的一个故事。致命ID啊，恐怖片也好，惊悚片也好，其实不是市场的最主流，对吧？因为它毕竟是一种。
虐啊虐呃虐感爽感啊，就就有点找自己找罪受嘛。但是嘞呃其实这几年应用是在往上走的，为啥呢？我们说密室题材这个。
剧本杀甚至是游戏哇之类这个鬼屋故事是用的是最多的。所以说这种类型我们必须学会今天来的同学啊来着了呃一个鬼屋制造一个群像。我会给大家讲点重要的口诀，好吧，我再次强调一下啊，致命ID是鬼屋这个类型片里面。
非常杰出的代表，他又开创了。
所谓人格分裂这一宗派啊，看一下知名ID的信息包。在讲这部电影的信息包的时候，我会把它每个阶段的。
呃，创作者意图也讲给你，所以同学们自己可以记一下笔记，我讲一遍信息包，你基本上就会写什么类型了。前提是我们都看过电影，知道剧情所有的走向啊。
来第一信息胞第一部分洗成转和四目式第一幕。
这部电影的私幕视言是比较明确的啊，第一幕第一个节拍啊第一分钟。
下雨的一个夜晚，公诉人心理医生在那查卷宗啊，在那播放一个人格分裂的嫌疑犯的一些录音啊，充斥着各种悬疑啊、血腥的气氛。因为是个杀人犯嘛。然后来这时候啊发现一些问题，联系这个公诉人想要紧急提审这个嫌疑人，因为嫌疑人马上就要被执行死刑了啊，有个时间锁。第二拍第4分钟。
同样是下雨的一个夜晚啊，给人的感觉是同一个时空发生正在发生的事情。因为都是下雨的夜嘛，汽车旅馆。
这个主偿景。
一对受伤的夫妇啊，那个老婆受伤了，对吧？他丈夫把他扶进来。
啊，第一组登场的人物。我们说这个旅馆就是后面那个鬼屋，这个咱们都理解啊。然后11个人物依次登场啊。这里呢首先这一家三口先登场，我们就丈叫他们丈夫妻子和小孩，我们就统一不说名字啊，全部说身份，然后开始往回闪回一下，回顾车祸的发生过程，也就是第三拍第五分钟。
回顾车祸发生过程的时候，一家三口是怎么出的车祸呢？是开车压到了一个高跟鞋，导致爆胎。然后镜头跟着这个高跟鞋又引出第四个人物登场。我们称之为妓女，我们就用身份说啊，然后高跟鞋呢就是他丢的，他遗失的。然后这个镜头再来到赵氏车上。
也就是撞死这呃撞了这个妻子的这个车，上面是两个人，一个是司机，一个是女演员，我们叫他司机和女演员。通过这通过这一个集中的事件，也就是这个车祸交代了一些基础的人设。比如说每个人基本的性格是怎么样，或者他是干什么然后来到第四盘。
也就是第10分钟。到现在为止，咱们的主场景旅馆里6个人物在主场景集合，也就是那一家三口，然后司机女星这6个人物来到旅馆集合，加上旅馆的店主，一共是7个人物登场。第五part。
11分钟，司机驾车出去找这个医生遇到妓女和情侣，然后一起回到旅馆。这时候呢9个人物完成了登场，加上店主啊，9个人物完成了登场，在旅馆集合。同时呢开始埋各种伏笔进行误导我们这里说是误导，是因为我们看过全片啊。
你看到这里的时候不认为是舞蹈，但是我们看过全片就知道他从这里开始就开始误导误导观众了。女性露腹呀，妓女被歧视，被调戏呀，那对小情侣貌合神离呀，司机竟然还有枪啊，然后那个房号从六变成9啊。
各种营造气氛紧张。同学们能理解我在说什么啊？在这里这些伏笔全都是误导，营造紧张气氛，后面是有用的。故事来到第六拍，也就是第17分钟，一辆警车赶到现场，警察啊押送一个犯人也来到主场军。
到此到此时此刻，11个人物集结完毕，然后呢营造这个犯人很吓人，营造这个警察呢也怪怪的，有疑点，对吧？然后到目前为止，主线索主线任务依然是救治伤者，警察协助司机推进救人。
这件事第一幕结束，所有人物在主场景集结完毕，同时浮现出来一个明面上的主线目标，就是拯救那个受伤的太太夫人。
然后这就是第一幕所有的完成的事情，主线目标清楚了。人务集接完成了。故事来到第二幕第七拍，从21分钟开始，所有人都入住下来以后，那相当于就是所有人都上路了嘛，都入住下来了嘛？就开始搞人物关系了，搞人物关系你可以理解为游戏时间。比如说警察调戏调戏妇女啊。
调戏调戏那个妓女啊，丈夫在那搞搞祈祷呀，司机偷摸吃点药啊，对吧？店主在那藏东西呀，对吧？藏起来营业执照上面的照片不是他呀。然后妓女包里也有一大堆赃款呀。
情侣就开始吵架呀，他们俩个是痛子成婚，然后他在吵架，这孩子到底谁的呀？
然后这个犯人呢就在那开始这个研究怎么把水管子起开，自己逃跑呀。
警察后背有血迹，对吧？这个警察也是怪怪的，把气氛推起来，把这个小小背提起来，BGM搞起来。我们说这是上路后的第一场啊第一拍故事来到第八拍24分钟，女演员手机响了，然后冒着雨出去找信号，被杀了，我们说这是第一个思想。
第九拍26分钟，司机呢迅速在洗衣房就发现了女演员的尸体啊，他这里没有做什么时间差，因为他要做那个倒计时，所以说他每一个死的人及时都被发现了啊。
司机发现了女业员的尸体，死状非常惨烈，同时呢也发现了10号号码，10号房的号码牌。在这里，目标线索指向了谁呀？死人我在课上讲过，这个悬疑啊，不要没有指向，不要上来跟我说死了人了。但是呢不知道谁杀的，完全不知道那可怎么办？
这样的话留不住观众给我指个人儿。在第九拍发现女演员尸体死状很惨的时候，指向的第一个目标是谁呀？
那肯定是那个犯人嘛，因为他是个杀人犯嘛，对不对？顺理成章。但是他们去找这个犯人的时候，发现犯人就逃跑了那非常明确了。既然这个犯人已经没有关在这里逃跑了，那必然是他杀。
然后第十拍30分钟，撇出去讲了一下另外一条线，也就是那个审问现场，对吧？那个那个呃呃法官和那个公诉人对于辩护人提出的嫌犯的分裂证，这个论据并没有什么耐心。但其实是再次点一下这个嫌犯是有人格分裂的。
然后回到主场景第1一拍来得计31分钟，旅馆里乱作一坛，因为死人了嘛，然后大家开始开会，开会的时候同时继续铺内部矛盾，继续搞内部撕裂。但是基本目标还是一致的，就是那个逃跑的犯人，来到第十二拍34分钟，司机和警察是两个最强的男人。
出去找逃跑的犯人，开始寻找各种线索。然后其他人留守，但是呢也逐步崩溃了。我们说其他人留守在这里没什么屌事情，要做什么？我展现人性的弱点，以及人物关系里面隐藏的危机。
包括那个店主去偷女演员的钱包啊，对吧？小情侣吵架呀，展现人性的弱点和人物关系里面的危机。我们说两个人去追寻明面上的主线目标，剩下的人那自然要展现这些撕裂，展现弱点，展现差异，展现人物关系。为什么？这就是我们设定群乡的意义啊，否则我们设这么多人干啥呀？11个主角。
对不对？设了11个主角，那那那。
当然要展现了。
然后来到第1十3拍，第40分钟，那个疑似杀手的那个影子又出现了啊，没有出现人出现了影子，那个女友逃脱了，那个男友被杀，这是第二个死者。第二个死者在第40分钟才出现啊。
然后来到第14盘，41分钟。
这个犯人呢拖着脚镣逃往了远方，结果逃了远方的房子，发现竟然还在旅馆啊，这时候呢就产生一些诡异的事呢。但是这时候观众实际上是发现诡异了，但是还没想明白。
他发现自己竟然还在旅馆里，然后警察逼近，把这个犯人逮住，并锁了起来。在这里是什么？
获得了一个虚假的胜利，杀人犯被抓住了，这是这里是第42分钟，全篇是80583分钟啊，标标准准的故事终点。同学们有没有发现一个问题，凡是好莱坞的片子全都贼准啊，为什么呢？因为他们的审片可能太严格了啊，故事进入第三幕，第15拍来到第43分钟。
回归平静，为啥呢？因为犯人抓到了嘛？那当然暂时回归了平颈，然后继续展现人性弱点呀，展现各种隐患呀，展现人物关系的变化呀。比如啊展现人物变化之后，司机整理2号死者的东西啊。
发现了9号号码牌，事情再次有了新的悬疑，新的转变，事情并不简单。9号、10号、9号吗？显然是有个倒计时嘛，因为那个角故事里员角色都都发现这个问题了，说这是个什么倒计时的意思吗？这时候。
为了强化这个故事转折，为了强化这个新的目标，来到故事第16拍49分钟，犯人又被杀了，他们认为的嫌疑人犯人被杀了，你不是怀疑他是杀人犯吗？结果他死了，这是第三个死者而且。
这个犯人所第三个死者，他身边有8号号码牌，这明显的交代了，第一，这个犯人并不是嫌犯，而且确实是90198再往下倒计时。这次的嫌疑无疑指向了那个店主。
那个鬼鬼祟祟的店主啊，旅店老板，然后呢他挟持那个妓女，又不小心碰开了冰箱里面藏着尸体，导致铁证无疑。大家都认为那肯定就是他才是凶手，不是那个犯人女，而且他也把犯人杀了。这时候店主选择了落荒而逃。故事来到第1七拍。
第51分钟，这个店主驾车逃跑，失手撞死了那一家三口当中的丈夫，也就是第四个死者。
故事来到第18趴52分钟，还又把故事切到那条那个申辩线啊，交代了继续交代嫌疑人的凶杀案呀、人格分裂呀，继续替嫌疑人去求情，说不能死刑。但但是这一次，嫌疑人到达了现场，给了正面的形象。
是一个光头死胖子。
故事来到第19趴54分钟，店主呢回到我们的主场景，店主交代他的冤屈啊，称一切都是个误会。警察不相信，但是其他人相信了他的话，认为呢还有其他嫌疑人。同学们再回顾一下啊，这个故事最早的目标是拯救那个。
夫人就伤。后来呢第二个目标是抓那个那个犯人。第三个目标呢是抓这个店主啊，但是店主又洗脱自己的冤情了啊。这时候呢故事也进入第三幕了，就开始要报一个神秘力量，明白这个意思吗？看这个节奏啊。
不断的死人指向了两个嫌疑人，第一个是犯人，第二个是吕店店主，对吧？这两个人都有重大的问题以及重大的这个作案动机嫌疑。但是都洗清了以后，这时候就要开始指向一些神秘力了，爆出这里曾是印第安人的墓地。
用这个来误导。
同时继续让剩下的人内部崩溃。然后大家决定在这里等到天亮不再行动。这时候大家做了一个新的决定啊，既然我们也搞不清楚到底是犯人也死了，店主也绑起来了，好像也不是他干的。这里呢好像有神秘力量，那我们就别动了，原地不动。
这时候有新的团队有了新的行动目标，叫原地不动。
那么故事来到第20盘57分钟。
在等候期间，大家开始在找彼此的共同点，试图破解谜题。因为大家发现这个倒计时的问题了啊，而且也不知道谁杀的，到底是不是鬼冤魂索命，还是说我们有什么共同点得罪过同一个人，对吧？剧情是无人生还，致敬了一下无人生还是吧？少。
然后故事来到第51排，第五个死者产生，就是那个太太一家三口当中的那个太太在这个死者产生的时候呢，之前给了一个伏笔，就是他的孩子进过房间。我们后面复盘，大然知道这是伏笔。然后这个夫人死了之后，这大家在死者的在尸体旁边发现6号号码。
悬疑就又起来了。
因为他们认为这个太太死的是受伤而死，是意外事物，身边怎么会有杀手扔下的号码牌来指示他是下一个呢？所以大家就很奇怪，那这时候呢就要去找上一个意外死亡的人，也就是所谓7号号码牌那里对吧？因为跳过了嘛，看过8号。
这里又看到6号，得去找7号，所以来到第22排第60分钟，他们去找这个丈夫的视频，在她的口袋里果然有7号牌。那么4。
这时候接连死去的5个人，身上分别有19876，倒计时5个号牌，现在唯一能解释的就肯定是子超自然的力量了。不是所谓的杀手。在这里大家彻底的慌了，开始要进入灵魂黑夜了，彻底慌了。大家认为呢。
肯定不是杀手，凶手那个犯人杀的，也不是店主杀的，只能是超自然的力量，就是印第人与冤魂所灭。那么既然判定了这个第23拍61分钟，决定让这个妇女孩子逃跑，对吧？此地不宜久留，结果呢？结果那个女友。
一对情侣那个男的已经挂了吗，女友和孩子所在的汽车爆炸了，他们理论上成为了第六个和第七个死者。
故事来到第24趴，也就是62分钟，尸体还不见了，戏氛变得更加诡异了。而且他们找了一圈，发现所有的尸体都不见了，都消失了。
我们说尸体为什么在这个点消失了啊，后面其实没有完全去解释。但是作为一个人格分裂的片子，倒也说得过去，但是尸体在这个点恰好完全消失了，因为再不消失，小孩要穿帮。
在这里呢基本上就确定是超自然的力量啊。我们说在这里呃死人死到极限了，人这个这个超自然力量也拉到极限了，进入灵魂黑夜已经彻底看不懂了。来进入第四幕故事进入最后一幕，来到25拍65分钟。
大家开始发现解决方案。我们说第四幕是提供解决方案的啊。第四幕，大家发现所有人的生日都是5月10号。另外呢所有人的姓氏都是地名，这太奇怪了，这不像一个真实的事情，十几个人，生日都是5月10号，这是不应该的。
在这时候呢开头吟唱过的那首关于精神分裂的诗歌，再次响起观众开始快要摸到答案了，对吧？这群人姓氏都是一样的，然后又反复提所谓的人格分裂。然后这时候人格分裂那首诗又读起来了，那基本上可以判定出这群人该不是人格分裂，都是同一个人吧。
然后既然观众猜到了，那也不藏着掖着了。第26拍67分钟又回到另外一条故事线，也就是申诉的那个现场司机的形象，司机的形象来到了这条故事线，彻底揭秘，这就是精神分裂的一场想象。他也是精神分裂患者的患者的其中一个人格而已。
其他所有的人格也都跟他一样啊，都是想象出来的。他们正在互相残杀，互相残杀。观众在这里已经完全明盘了啊，都了解怎么回事了啊。所以说这不是说两条不实线，是被审判的人的大脑活动和外在活动，被审判的人外在在应对一旁人的审判，他的内在。
正在想象这一群人，他自己想象出来的这一群人在互相在经历一个雨夜鬼雾，解释了啊同一个时空发生的两件事情，一个是患者大脑内部发生的事情，一个是患者大脑身体外面发生的事情。然后回到27盘。我们说第四步要解密了以后要有新的解决方案嘛。
第二期7拍新的解决方案非常明确，司机要回到旅馆，找出凶手，并杀掉对方。也就是说，这11个人格里面是有一个凶手的。
前面死的那六七个人是被一个凶手杀死的司机回到。
回到这个幻想的旅馆里，杀死那个凶手，就能拯救他的母体。也就是我们的这个精神人格分裂这个患者，他的母体他脑子里面有11个人格，要是杀掉那个，其中有一个人格是个杀人犯，其中有一个人格是杀成性，几年前也犯过连环杀人案，现在又在连环杀人，杀如果能够。
杀掉那个人格。
说不定这个小胖子这个光头胖子就得救了。好，那既然产生了这个新的解决方案，来到第28趴。
72分钟。
这个妓女想逃跑，发现车子已经被破坏了，同时也发现了警察的假身份。他其实是个犯人，这时候再次产生了新的嫌疑人，或者是说最后一个嫌疑人。我们说之前谁都当过嫌疑人啊，都谁当过嫌疑人啊？
犯人当过嫌疑人。
店主当过选疑员。
印第安灵魂当过嫌疑人，现在又变成了警察，成为了嫌疑人，而且这次似乎是最后一个嫌疑人了。故事来到第29拍，从观众的角度，观众又有新的期待新的目标了啊，去理解这个故事的悬疑和期待是怎么做的啊，来到第29拍74分钟。
警察要杀掉这个妓鱼灭口，关键时刻谁救了他，店主手救了他。但是呢店主救了妓女，但是被警察杀死了，成为了第八个死者啊，店主也嘎也嘎了，来到第30盘75分钟，警察就追这个妓女，司机赶来救他，可警察正面硬刚啊。
拿枪对射，两个人同归于尽。
他们两个人是第九和第10个，也就是说司机回到现场，他知道了自己只是一个精神分裂的人格，所以他也没打算活下去，对吧？他不打算把生的希望留给自己，他只要留给一个善良的人就可以了。你同学们理解我在说什么吗？就这十几个人格呀，只要灭掉那个会杀人的人格就可以了。
其他人格谁活下去都行，而且这个妓女活下去更好。因为他本来就是那个最有希望的人，对生活充满希望的人，他干了最后一片，他想要去买一个果园去经营一个果园是吧？他是最好的那个人啊，他把希望留给了妓女。
也就是说第30分钟啊，第30拍75分钟这里嗯，我们的司机和这个最后一个嫌疑人警察同归于尽啊。
We, stay there, stay there.
ok hold stay with meO1, two, three.
感觉好见一会不。
嗯哎。
有我也 you跟活，我的你是我成给我你说。
31拍来到79分钟，既然所有的人格都已经杀死了，只剩下了一个妓女，带着希望回到家乡。同时我们的嫌疑犯也恢复了平静。
然后辩护人呢就据理力争，法官也同意了让这个嫌疑犯暂时不用执行死刑了。到这里啊，故事基本上就讲完了，但是呢还给了一个果园的镜头，你就知道没有那么简单了。来到第32盘多出来一场戏，第80分钟。
天晴了，我们说在这个故事里第一次出现晴天，天晴了。
妓女经营着果园音乐很舒缓，这个患者呢跟妓女隔空对唱，对吧？因为这个妓女就是患者心中的希望，所以两个人同时在唱同一首歌是非常正常的，一切非常美好，但是肯定没有这么简单，因为这场戏是多出来的。本来在上一场就应该结束掉了。在第31拍整个故事就应该结束掉的。
但是加了这个32拍，你就知道后面还有反转。
最后的反转彩蛋是第33盘，81分钟，妓女挖出了一号号码牌，显然危险还没有消除，他是最后那个死者，一转身杀手是那个小男孩。
想想也合理，小男孩的尸体也从来没出现过，小男孩的号码牌也没有出现过，赶紧用闪回交代了之前一切都是小孩干的。小男孩一直有很好的位置，呃，很容易作案的动机，因为也不受注意，所以说这里赶紧用闪回交代了一下小男孩每次是怎么作案的，省得观众在这里呃这个这个发飙是吧？省得观众在这里不愿意了。
然后小男孩获胜了，他把黑手伸向了这个妓女，也伸向了正在陪他治疗的那个医生。两条线同时再次杀人。也就是说根本没有消灭杀人的那魂啊，故事在第83分钟结束。整个故事83分钟33拍啊，83分钟结束的时候。
再次想起了那首关于精神分裂的诗歌。
首先我们来说一下这个故事不好做的地方有哪些啊？
第一个就是这个群像，咱们经常强调鬼屋要设计群像。
对不对？
看一下这部电影群像设计的就较宝马啊。嗯很多同学说这个设计形像就是设计阶层啊，设计穷的，设计富的，其实不是这样的啊，嗯群像是社会形形色色的人。但是这些人呢之间要有张力。比如说你看警察和他押送的嫌犯。
奉子成功的小情侣，但这个女的呢是假怀孕，一家三口这个假店主是吧？然后这个司机和女明星。
同学们可以看一下为什么所谓的不要设定群项，就是因为这个群像啊，首先。
它有两个好处。第一个好处，我们说群校他本来是有自己的。
社会地位和社会行为的。但是进到一个密室当中面对压力。
会发生变化，这个是喜欢看。
第二件事情还有个什么好处呢？就是出现嫌疑，出现悬疑，到底谁杀的时候，我们在分析的时候，我们在判断的时候可以更有这个脚头。
你知道啊这里面的事儿可以更复杂。
所以说鬼屋必须设定群项，对吧？我在课上给你们讲过，设定群项最基本的原因是你人得够死呀，对吧？当然了，那种只是表面原因，你一个一个死，你人少了不够死的，对不对？
本质上的原因是还是要展现形形色色的压力以及形形色色的悬疑。
所以说同学们对于这部电影啊，先学学习一下这种人设啊，是一个人设，这种叫鬼屋的。
群像设计啊，仿照我们的国情，你自己想象一下，那我布置一个作业，我让你设定。
一个鬼屋里面的10个人。
下一个我们要学的事情自己记一下啊。
就这种故事。
实际上是没有主角。
没有主角。
那这个主线怎么推进呢？
观众的视线如何安放？
靠共同的目标。
共同的目标实际上是共同的悬疑。
到底谁是凶手，到底谁干的？
只不过这个悬悬疑我强调过。
要有对象。
家才愿意follow。
你可以理解到底是谁杀的这个悬疑牵着干到最后的。
但是呢我们一路上要给指引。
给过哪些指业？
犯人。
店主。
印第安神秘力量是吧？然后那个警察。
给了四次之意。
然后我们再回来接着说这个视角问题同学们。
我们说观众视角实际上是上级视角。
他与故事当中的角色。
是不是？
有信息差。
观众看到的比每一个角色都略微多那么一丢丢。然后在这部电影里面。
创作者用这个信息插干啥了呢？
扰乱观众的视听。
获得的信息全是无用信息。
而且这样扰乱观众。
观众没有一种没有很强烈的被耍了的感觉。
因为人家不是故意的，当然他是故意的啊，严格律事上说他是故意的，但是你相对容易接受。
他并不是某个角色发明了发现了一个什么线索，然后在那瞎分析，然后在那往下探查，然后误导观众。
都是你自己看去。
人家可没这么说。
主线来说。
其实观众跟角色的信息差就干了这么点小事情。
那么综合下来就能分析出来这部电影它的优势是什么？
首先在200几年的时候，这个故事结构是非常创新的。
然后他套的皮是什么呢？他核心讲的是人格分裂的故事，但它的外在实际上就是一个鬼屋杀人事件。
偷掉那个人格分裂这条线，这个故事也是一个独立存在的六分片。
所以我们来总结一下。
关于鬼屋片的一般创作方式，从这里开始记笔记。
第一。
设计群像。
主角一定是主角群啊，设计群像。
第二。
设计一个集中的场景，让所有人走不掉。
用复杂的人物关系和人物设定。
进行风险暗示。
也就是这这群人之间是有风险的这是环境。
第四。
明面上要有个假任务。
把观众拖住。
这个故事里面的假人物就是拯救那个受伤的富人，别啥事没有啊，明面上有个任务，别来了就等死。
先要去办点事儿，比如说没电了，要修好电，或者是要把要去门口那个储藏间拿食物回来。
要有一个明面的任务。
才能撑过。
然后进进入第五个环节，就是人逐个死。
你设计群像了吗？人的艾格斯。
第六个环节指向几个具体的嫌疑目标。
在这个故事里面，我们可以说它指向了4个具体的嫌疑目标。
当然了，他四个都是假的，一般来说第四个是真的是吧？指向几个具体的嫌疑目标啊，不一定是。
然后下一趴在这个过程当中，逐步把人性弱点都暴露出来。
你刚才设计的群像吗？涉及那么多弱点，涉及那么多人物关系吗？把所有的雷全部给我爆掉。
暴露出每个人的阴暗面，偷东西的、通奸的、撒谎的，有秘密的，是吧？
全部暴露。
然后下一盘。
干掉最后一个目标。
不是收掉。
然后下一盘再给一个反转，出人意料的反转。
不一定是嫌疑人上的主人医疗反转，也可以给别的。
比如说某个人没死，比如说某个人逃跑了，比如说冤枉了什么。
反正再次给出一个反转。
记下来了吧。
今天我们这节课我说过，我们难得讲鬼屋，就是要一次性把高分鬼屋的写法给我学会。
虽然它是B级片啊，虽然它是但是未来的市场还是很大的。
比如说游戏，比如说剧玩啥是吧？比如说密室逃脱都是套这类故事。
所以说非常有必要学会写这种类型。
然后。
这个片子还有一点值得我们学习，就是两线虚实啊两线虚实。嗯，你可以理解另外一条审判线也当然也可以是回忆线，对吧？当然也可以是其他的线。
两线蓄设的时候啊，为了防止另外一条线比较无聊啊，要用标志性的东西来穿插。
在这部片子里面呢，就首先用了一个天气，两边都是瓢过大雨。
同时呢又用了一个诗歌啊，那个诗歌三次响起。
用一首诗。
吟唱轻轻的吟唱。
穿察两个虚事线。
难免就要故弄玄虚，也不叫故弄玄虚吧，就制造紧张气氛啊，我们可以看一下来，我们来看一下这个。
制造紧张气氛的一些典型的戏，就是明明不紧张，但是他把紧张气氛做出来啊。
来看一下。
第五趴，比如说第五趴。
司机来到这个旅馆啊，错。
多点。
I mean, it's dead end Yeah, well if you don't mind, I got to try.
Okay, that would be $30 cash, please.
哎。
Didn't you used to be that actress?
Yes.
Now, is that a nice room?
Because though我们说这里就是我说的啊，开始用复杂的人物管权人物设定进行风险暗示，不断的暗示。后面还有一场这种戏，我们先看这一场。
It's very cozy.
我个。
要放你。
的小风不 wants to know.
We're a little stuck here, George, I don't think we can get out tonight.
嗯。
营造紧张气氛啊呃来我们看一下进入第二幕的第一场上真正上路以后啊。
这的问题。
喂结嗯再见。
确实。
shallow steady just keep comfortable. Then we should take radio Thats right. No, it's not. I can manage.
你。
开具的直先上去看。
是。
这要存证人。
You better.
变更。
也没意。
you.
你确不明。
什么？
目了啊，所有人就开始上路了，都在这住下来，开始展现每个人的。
来偷东西的偷东西。刚才这就是第二幕的开场戏，明白这意思吧？
配着BGM所有人就上路了。然后接下来下一场开始对吧，是吧？演员第一个嘛，明白这个道理啊。
所以说像这样的故事哎没有明确的主角，也没有明确的任务线但是故事的字募依然十分的清晰，对不对？你要跟着目标而走。
对吧跟着整个事态的发展走。
我们进到这个地方是要死人的，然后随人的住下，然后开始死，抓到凶手，然后呢发现不对，还要再抓另外一个啊，但是打不过灵魂黑夜，然后解决方案。第四幕。
明白吗？故事啊结构还是非常清晰的啊，再次再次强调一下，你像这种好莱坞的电影啊还是非常的规整的啊，非常规整。因为他们的审片环节比较复杂，好不好？
那关于这部片子的学习啊，就是咱们今天的呃内容。
。